lack of understanding and a lack of
seeing the humanity of folks who look
like Rashida T Cory bush is another
member of the Hamas caucus she's sort of
I would say she's the dumbest of all of
them AOC like she's she's kind of like
an idiot but she's very calculating and
she knows how to use media so I put her
as the leader Rashida is like the most
committed and she's like a genuine
racist I put ilhan in that bucket Cory
bush is just like the extra one that
they were like could we just find an
idiot who could just like scream and
Flack and swing her arms all over the
place and scream a bunch of stuff that
she has no idea what she's talking about
and they were like yeah yeah we found
Cory Bush here she is of a a lack of
care and a lack of understanding and a
lack of seeing the humanity of folks who
look like Rashida Talib it's outrageous
that my colleagues are blatantly
blatantly attempting to silence the only
Palestinian American representative
right here um it's outrageous but it's
not surprising and let me tell you it's
not surprising because this place is
where 17 00 members of Congress this
elected body enslaved black people it's
not surprising because they thought it
was right it's not surprising because
this is a place where members continue
to claim that the Insurrection on the
capital just appear to look like a
normal tourist visit it's not surprising
because this is the place where our
black and brown staff members repeatedly
speak of experiencing racism and sexism
islamophobia get pushed off of elevators
xenophobia and more right here in this
workplace this is the place and let me
say this she Mourns for the 1400 is
right she Mourns for the 10,000 and she
will not stop no time sees fire now and
she takes the death threats that you all
send that that gent lady is no longer
recognized the gentleman from Maryland
to Hur the desire to save lives is
greater gentle gentleman from Maryland
is recognized what I
said note that I don't have to scream
nor or wave my arms nor thrash around my
head or have trouble breathing when I
tell you that that woman is a deeply
anti-American
anti-white bigot and buffoon see how
easy that was that was easy I don't even
know that I had a heartbeat during that
whole thing it was very very easy to do
but what these people do is overly emote
and they act again
laring live action role playing they are
pretending to believe any of the things
that they said nobody cares that Rashida
Talib is Palestinian it's because she
supports Hamas and if she really cared
about the Palestinian people she would
want them liberated from Hamas again
Israel has not had a citizen in Gaza
since 2005 the entire world would have
loved that place to turn into the second
great place uh on the Mediterranean
Coast right there there with Tel Aviv
just miles south right and thrown it in
the Jews face see we made a place even
nicer than Tel Aviv they could have done
it they could have done it but instead
they literally took pipes that were sent
to them to build water infrastructure
under the ground and they turned it into
Rockets So thus when you have to defend
bad ideas and bad people you have to
scream and you have to thrash around and
go completely
berserk